Von Teleskopen bis zum Large Hadron Collider
hat jedes neue wissenschaftliche Werkzeug die Fragen neu erfunden,
die wir als Wissenschaftler
und neugierige Köpfe sinnvoll stellen können.
High Performance Computing – kurz HPC –
hat sich in den Sechzigern in diese elite Riege eingereiht. Heute
klopfen Quantencomputer an dieselbe Tür.
Willkommen! Mein Name ist Iskandar Sitdikov
und ich bin Software-Ingenieur hier bei IBM Quantum.
In diesem Kurs möchten wir Studierenden
und Fachleuten zeigen, wie Quantencomputing schon bald
gemeinsam mit HPC-Infrastrukturen
rechenintensive Aufgaben lösen wird.
Du wirst lernen, wie Quanten-
und klassische Computer kommunizieren und Daten austauschen,
wie man Programme schreibt, die beide Hardwaretypen nutzen,
und wie diese Integration neue Anwendungen ermöglicht, die wir heute noch nicht lösen können.
Du sammelst praktische Erfahrung mit echter Quantenhardware
und klassischen Hochleistungsrechen-Clustern,
führst Quantenjobs neben herkömmlichen HPC-Workloads aus
und lernst, Ergebnisse sicher zu interpretieren,
sowie Stellen zu erkennen, wo Quantenbeschleunigung
Berechnungen wirklich verbessern kann
– und wo nicht. Vor allem aber wirst du verstehen,
wohin die Zukunft des Computings führt
und welchen Weg wir dorthin einschlagen werden. Wir glauben,
dieser Kurs ist sowohl wichtig
als auch zeitgemäß, und wir sind überzeugt,
dass die Kombination dieser Technologien entscheidend sein wird,
um einen rechnerischen Vorteil zu erzielen.
Das könnte weitreichende Auswirkungen auf Branchen haben
wie die Chemie – womöglich durch schnelleres
Medikamentendesign und Materialforschung –,
den Finanzbereich
mit intelligenteren Risikomodellen
und Betrugserkennung, sowie künstliche Intelligenz und maschinelles Lernen
für die Modelloptimierung. In diesem Kurs
tauchen wir tief in Computerressourcen,
Programmiermodelle und Quantenalgorithmen ein.
Also herzlich willkommen – und viel Spaß!
Es gibt einiges zu besprechen.